Brian how do you feel about distribution
today compared to 2007 it's very
different even in that even in that that
short amount of time
Steel City what has been my most
successful and widely distributed movie
and that was back when DVDs still had a
healthy shelf-life and what they call
like sell through or whatever there's
all these distribution terms and jargon
but that was when blockbuster was still
relatively healthy there and they bought
a lot of units and you know that was a
tangible thing to see your movie in a
blockbuster you know
well obviously the Internet and Netflix
has changed everything with all the
streaming again it goes back to what I
said before I think it's devalued a lot
of things so instead of being people or
visual or visual human being so instead
of walking into a store or something or
and seeing like a wall of movies and
being able to say oh I want to see this
or I want to see that we're at the mercy
of what these content providers show us
online so what is Netflix when they get
all these new movies what do they choose
to feature what do they choose to put on
their new releases er so we're at the
mercy of them and it's just and then you
know there's these these things called
slotting fees which is another thing
where you have to pay to be in certain
areas or certain you know you're
basically paying to be in front of
people's eyes and who has the money to
do that the studios so you know it's
going to continue to be an uphill battle
for independent films and unless you
have a studio acquire an independent
film like a Weinstein Company or a Sony
Pictures Classics who has the muscle and
has the resources and the money to get a
movie a little independent film into the
front of everyone's eyes unless you have
that you're just like a minnow in a sea
of great white sharks I mean that's
really and if you're a lucky minnow that
can figure out a way to eat to go to the
bottom and like eat a little
food and then like go back you know if
you're able to savour survive with all
these great whites like around then
you're lucky otherwise you're just like
you're out there and you get a little
bit of life and then you just get
swallowed by a shark you know like these
all these independent films that come
out they're out and all these film
makers gonna say hey go see my movie on
Netflix go rent my movie on Amazon and
it's cool for like two months and the
Netflix doesn't renew your contract the
movies not doing well on Amazon and then
it's just you know it's just out there
and then people say what have you done
and you say I did a movie called joint
body never heard of it
well it's on Netflix and Amazon never
heard of it you know but if you say I
did captain Phillips oh I saw that movie
good movie
you